[Typewriter Sounds]
Good morning, John, it's Tuesday March 6th, and I am entirely surrounded by one hundred Peeps.
We found the Peeps.
The bunnies count as full size, right?
I think I'm gonna get the bunnies, because they're sort of more swallowable.
They look more like the shape that won't choke me to death.
I've just discovered something very interesting.
It says that four bunnies are 31 grams, and that they contain 33 grams of carbohydrates.
There's actually more sugar than there is bunny in these bunnies.
Good news on the cheapskate front, each one of these is only 99 cents, so I'm going to get out of the store paying exactly 6 dollars.
So, now Target has six of my dollars and I have one hundred of their Peeps.
I would also like to announce that I have completed the first Brotherhood 2.0 Book Club book.
Yes, I have finished We Wish to Inform You That Tomorrow We Will Be Killed With Our Families by Philip Gourevitch.
And since I don't have enough time to discuss that book and eat one hundred Peeps, I'm going to discuss the book while eating 100 Peeps.
On your mark, get set...
Now there're some discussions on Brotherhood 2.0 about We Wish to Inform You Tomorrow We Will Be Killed With Our Families.
About how it's a book designed to make you feel guilty.
About something that's already happened.
And there's no use crying over spilt milk.
One gallon per every dead person.
800,000 gallons of milk.
But what Philip Gourevitch's book really about
was understanding that something happened,
in Rwanda.
Something very significant on a worldwide scale.
Unlike eating Peeps.
I only ate half of this one, why'd I do that?
Beyond acknowledging it, it's about understanding how something like that could happen.
I mean, in a matter of days, 800,000 people were killed.
All you have to have is the right cocktail of,
international indecision,
local alcoholism,
long-term racism,
and a couple of inflammatory people with control over the media,
and it is absolutely possible for completely normal, healthy people,
to become genocidal maniacs.
To commit the worst crime that, so far, humanity is capable of committing.
[unintelligible fast-forwarding]
It wasn't just bad people killing bad people, it was a bad situation, and that when we can recognize
those ingredients being poured together in the stew again,
we can put a lid on it, before the fumes reach a nation wide furor and create another genocidal scenario.
World governments,
need to recognize it as possible, and individual citizens need to realize it as possible.
So that they can pressure their governments.
[Coughs]
That was not me almost puking, that's just the bad taste of the Peep.
Ugh, 5:16.
I'm not gonna be able to finish this one.
It's too late, I'm so glad.
Six minutes is up.
That Peep was just sticking to my finger.
Ah, and I'm not gonna eat this half a Peep. I had that many.
Which honestly, I think is pretty good.
[Burps]
I'm feeling kind of jittery.
I really haven't eaten anything else today, that is all I've eaten.
That is 100% of the food I've eaten today. OH!
It doesn't feel very good though.
Ugh.
I can't, I can't see, I ...
I hate their little eyes.
So now I have to go online and contribute 82.75 dollars to the Brotherhood 2.0 Foundation to Decrease Suck Levels Worldwide.
Think what we could do with that money!
Plus the 20 I already donated and plus the 20 you already donated, that's like 127.5 dollars.
WOAH!
Um, this video is longer than four minutes, please don't punish me because I'm doing a punishment, and we haven't made that an official rule yet.
But I'm making it a rule now.
From now on, videos must be less than four minutes and this is the last one that will be more than four minutes.
That is a rule as of tomorrow.
Which is when I will see you.
Who wants Peeps?!